[Musique]
prête serment mourir nc die je jure de
ne jamais dire deux mots qui ne soit
vrai de le fabriquer aucune arme
destinée à tuer
jamais utilisé le pouvoir de l'unique
comme une arme
tu sais ce que veut dire assez
d'ailleurs langues anciennes
ces reventes de tous
[Musique]
ce sont elles qui sort je monde
je n'ai pas choisi ce chemin oui je le
suivrai
où allons-nous à deux rivières le 106 1
cuil profondément dans ces montagnes
espérons que ça les a préparés à ce qui
va déferler
le ténébreux se réveille
il y en aura un qui s'élèvera contre lui
et c'est l'un d'autres sports
vous avez perdu l'esprit votre vie ne
sera pas celle que vous imaginiez
barrette
qu'est ce que c'est sur l'armée il
arrive
on nous faire
protéger ceux que nous aimons
quel qu'en soit le prix
ennemis sont partout
ne laisseront rien sur leur passage
nous avons déjà perdu trop de monde
je refuse de perdre
ça n'arrivera pas
ne restons pas le ténébreux maintenant
dentier se consumera
je me permettrai parle
la route is comme elle l'entend
tu crois qu'on rentrera un jour
chez nous
non